[Musique]
j'arrive salsa passe au noble elle et
ils s'en sont donnés de la peine pour
exécuter les pas des danses latines en
rythme
sous l'oeil expert de Christophe et
Coralie Licata les chorégraphes des
stars la compétition de cette 13e
édition du festival vitadance a réuni
les plus jeunes les adolescents et les
seniors ce matin place au solo en
matinée et aux danses de couple
l'après-midi mais avant tout place à
l'élégance
alors moi principalement je crois qu'il
a danse parce que surtout j'adore le
fait que le fait qu'on doit se
mettre lolirock tout ça principalement
alors la danse a développé une certaine
confiance quand il s'agit de parler
devant les gens parce que ils ont de la
danse c'est une façon de communiquer
[Musique]
porte aussi la joie moi ça me permet en
tout cas de me libérer et ça fait déjà
plus de 10 ans que je danse et c'est
aussi du coup une passion d'enfance j'ai
commencé avec la danse classique et en
fait en découvrant plusieurs styles de
danse bah je suis tombée on va dire
amoureuse du sport
c'est l'école tempo danse Academy de la
possession qui a organisé ce festival 6
jours d'événements autour de la danse et
200 danseurs participants pro et
amateurs
les compétitions du festival Vita danse
permettent vraiment à nos danseurs de se
motiver toute l'année pour s'entraîner
pour performer pour aller toujours plus
haut toujours plus loin on est là pour
leur donner cette scène cet espace
d'expression c'est un moment de
rencontre et d'échanges aussi et c'est
surtout l'occasion de rencontrer les
danseurs Stark qu'ils ont l'habitude de
voir uniquement à la télé
et justement que pensent le chorégraphe
des stars du niveau réunionnais
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé plein d'énergie déjà en tout
cas avec plein de sourires c'était
exactement ce que on attend dans une
compétition surtout qui prennent du
plaisir et ça c'est le cas est-ce que je
me rends compte surtout c'est qu'à la
Réunion il y a un gros niveau de danse
et je m'attendais pas à un niveau si
élevé donc très difficile à juger mais
en tout cas super beau à regarder si
l'enthousiasme est communicatif en avant
la musique les pas suivront la relève
elle est déjà là
[Musique]